quakecon with the thing that happened
recently and bethesda took the
opportunity to reveal some new details
about fallout 4s perks and companions it
turns out your canine companion dog meat
is modeled on the lead designers dog
which is definitely something you need
to know and they filmed it doing all
sorts of things to make the look of the
digital version more realistic just like
Infinity Ward did with call of duty
ghosts dog meat can be found early in
the game when you leave the vault and it
seems he'll be a pretty handy sidekick
since he can be sent into buildings to
explore for loot as you go off and do
more important things other companions
include mr. handy the robot assistant
Preston Garvey who leads the
Commonwealth Minutemen faction which you
can join and Piper a charismatic and
manipulative resident of Fenway Park
near diamond city all your human
companions are romantical regardless of
gender and there are a dozen possible
companions all up there are also special
perks you can learn to assist you if you
prefer to play without a companion
speaking of which the game reaches 70
perks all of which have their own set of
ranks which amount to 275 different
iterations while a number of animations
have been created through immersion
captcha faces are procedurally animated
meaning that there are predefined mouth
movements that correspond to letters and
syllables so Thursday also revealed that
mobile game fallout shelter will make
its way to Android devices next month
for more fallout 2 goodness and
everything else that matters in gaming
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot